[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com an absolutely stunning scheme
has been uncovered to falsely accuse
wait for it special prosecutor robert
muller of sexual assault in order to do
what discredit the Trump Russia
investigations maybe try to push the
midterms towards Republicans which now
are just six days away we talk about
projection from the Trump administration
on the program often and there's
projection and then there's projections
so let's go through some examples Obama
is terrible on the debt and deficit the
reality is Republicans don't really care
about the debt and deficit and Trump has
blown it up just like george w bush did
another example fake news slamming the
Trump administration is a huge problem
in reality it's the Trump administration
that are actually the purveyors of the
fake news not the victims of it one more
example before I get to this one voter
fraud and voter impersonation are huge
problems reality they're very rare
but those most frequently arrested for
voter impersonation voter fraud trying
to vote twice are people on the right
who are trying to prove a point about
how easy it is to commit the fraud turns
out it's not so easy because they've
gotten caught many times now and then we
get to the ultimate projection which is
about false sexual assault allegations
the right insists and I've interviewed
some of them that the real problem
around sexual assault is not victims
opting not to come forward because of
stigma and fear it is not the epidemic
that some claim exists when it comes to
domestic violence instead
violence but they claim that the real
problem is there are simply too many
fake rape and sexual assault allegations
and that it's too easy to get people in
trouble and here they are caught
planning false sexual assault
allegations against robert muller and
they got caught originally independent
journalist scott Steadman wrote in The
Guardian that a smear campaign was
imminent and he tweeted about it
yesterday
saying I wasn't going to report on this
but I think my fears are coming true
based on information that I am privy to
I believe false accusations will be
spread about Muller in order to
discredit him and possibly the
journalists who are preparing this story
the Atlantic is reporting that a company
run by approached from conspiracy
theorists has been offering to pay women
to make false sexual assault allegations
against Robert Muller the Muller team is
aware of it a spokesman for Muller says
that they've referred this scam to the
FBI for further investigation several
journalists were contacted by a woman
claiming to be called Loraine Parsons as
well as one named Jennifer Taub they
both had pretty similar stories which
were that a man claiming to work for
surefire insurance hired by Republican
activist Jack Burkman offered them about
$20,000 to make accusations against
Robert Muller of sexual harassment
workplace harassment sexual misconduct
now are these even women who are
connected to Robert Muller well it's not
totally clear at least with one of them
Parsons claimed that she worked for
Muller 44 years ago and barely saw him
at a law firm but the law firm that was
cited says we have no record of this
woman ever working for us the man she
spoke to allegedly offered to pay off
her credit card debt and give her 20
grand and then Jennifer Taub is the
other woman who was contacted similar
offers were made and this guy Berkman
was a big pusher of that Seth rich DNC
murder conspiracy theory as well not
surprisingly that he's running in this
circles in these
articles and I you know Pat there's
another element to this which I kind of
hesitate to even get into which is that
there's this Republican kid named Jacob
Wall who is like very popular on Twitter
and Trump often retweets him and it
appears that there's a connection
between him and this story he was pre
promoting the story yesterday the day
before yesterday I believe and it turns
out that the registration of this
company sure fire insurance is connected
to Jacob walls mom and I you know I
don't even know if we we should or need
to get into that but like this stinks at
every level yeah I'm not even familiar
with this person but it certainly does
think at every level and I'm just
thinking even if these allegations were
true and there were actual sexual
assault allegations made against Muller
that wouldn't that wouldn't end the
investigation certainly he would have to
step down I think but someone would
replace him it's not like every
allegation made against Trump and
potential collusion between Trump and
Russia would go out the window because
Muller went down over some reason like
this yeah that's a fair point like Trump
was on tape talking about grabbing by
the [ __ ] you can just do it when you're
famous you don't even have to ask and he
was elected president like even if there
was a credible allegation against Robert
Mulder from 44 years ago does it
actually even relate to his credibility
running this investigation this
investigation doesn't even have to do
really with sexual assault although
Donald Trump has it has to do with
someone who has been accused by dozens
of women or more than a dozen women the
bad news though is that there are people
on the right who think that the story is
Muller has been accused of sexual
assault
even though really the story is that
people have been caught offering to pay
money to women to make fake allegations
against Robert Muller there are people
and I've seen some of the discussions
online who think that Muller has
actually been accused and you've got the
misreporting combined with the confusion
combined with the ignorance that is sort
of the baseline of politics on the right
in the United States right now and you
still end up with a story that's going
to have to be discredited and like with
voter fraud they are the
source of the false rape allegations and
they got caught and we'll see what the
follow-up is hey I have just a
disgusting story that I have to tell you
about we've been talking all week about
the shooting in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
at the Tree of Life synagogue that left
11 people dead and more people injured
at the hands at the barrel at the end of
a barrel of an extremist right-wing
shooter and in response there have been
all sorts of efforts made to reach out
to the Jewish community local Muslim
communities in Pittsburgh have raised
significant amounts of money to pay for
the funerals of the victims of the
shooting in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
there's a million-dollar fundraiser
which yesterday was at seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for the victims
of the synagogue shooting I don't know
exactly where it is today there have
been vigils all over the country I was
just talking to some friends earlier
today who attended one in Northampton
Massachusetts yesterday starting
downtown at the old home of the David
Pakman show and ending at the synagogue
in Northampton Massachusetts and similar
events all over the country I received
emails from many people who know that I
am regularly targeted by anti-semitic
screeds and tirades and just messages of
support so Mike Pence campaigning for
Republicans decided he was going to get
in on the action after this shooting
took place at a synagogue and since it's
a week the week before the midterm
elections he decided to invite one of
the wackiest flavors of rabbis and I
hesitate to even really call the guy a
rabbi he's part of what's called I call
them Jews for Jesus I think they're more
properly known as Messianic Jews and
they are Jews who unlike Jews believe
that Jesus is the Messiah and we could
talk a lot about Messianic Jews I've
even appeared on the programs there was
there's this guy called Michael Brown
who has a very homophobic right-wing
radio show who has interviewed me
previously and he claims to be Jewish
and a Christian and a Jew for Jesus and
whatever I want to play for you the
first clip and to most of you this
Gong sound like any Jew I've ever heard
of before if you know what I mean right
this guy's called Lauren Jacobs and here
he is a Jewish guy because there was a
shooting at a progressiva Galit Aryan
synagogue and this is the guy that they
find talking about Jesus God of Abraham
god of Isaac God of Jacob God and father
of my Lord and Savior Yeshua Jesus the
Messiah and my God and Father - you are
real and you know everything and you are
powerful and you are good and you are
able to hear and answer prayers please
hear and answer my prayers now Oh Lord
my god
your divinely inspired and true word
tells us unless you Lord build the house
the builders are wasting their efforts
they are building in vain a political
party is like those builders you might
notice it doesn't really sound like Jew
and instead of praying for the victims
of the synagogue attack he did pray for
the Republican candidates that are
running I pray that you would enable
vice president Pence to continue to
fulfill his many important
responsibilities with excellence I pray
for Attorney General Bill Schuette who's
running for governor for congressman
Mike Bishop who is running again for
Congress for Lena Epstein who was
running for Congress for John James who
was running for the Senate I pray for
them and for the Republican Party and
its candidates that they would honor you
and your ways that you might grant them
victory in this election this is a
message okay this is a way to kowtow to
the Jews and allies who are willing to
support Republicans without alienating
the extremist base which is often
anti-semitic you bring a Jew for Jesus
and to be very clear I don't care about
the religious views here
okay I'm Jewish by community I'm Jewish
by culture I'm Jewish by ethnicity I'm
not religious this is not about the
believing of Jesus to be the Messiah
Jews are mostly liberal in the United
States in 2008 it was either high 70s or
low 80s percent voted for Obama okay
this is one of the most liberal voting
groups in the country the synagogue that
was shot up where eleven people died and
more were injured was a progressive
egalitarian synagogue to say okay Jews
were shot let's bring a rabbi and bring
this guy to pray for Republican
candidates is disgusting and these
people have no shame they are vile
disgusting and depraved and this is you
know Pat how we've been talking about
those signals it's another wink wink nod
nod moment that yeah we're with the
Jewish people because they got shot but
we're bringing a Republican Jew for
Jesus who has almost no shared traits
whatsoever with the majority of the
Jewish community in the United States
and it is a pandering attempt and it is
absolutely vile and as an now as a non
Jew Pat do you get why it's so
disgusting or is this does it just seem
like a Jews a Jew I don't know well I
wasn't familiar that there are even are
Jews for Jesus I thought Jews for Jesus
were just Christians and that if you
accept Jesus as the Messiah then you're
a Christian so this is all very new to
me and it's astonishing how the Trump
people were able to mess this up it
seems like a slam dunk you just you just
invite some running the mill rabbi right
someone who's going to give speech
that's a political and who in some ways
matches with the ideology of the people
at that synagogue who were shot up and
and they managed to mess it up it's it's
ridiculous yeah and I would actually
argue that they may not even see it as
messing it up I mean I think that they
did it deliberately and to make this
even worse the Messianic Jews are
denouncing this particular guy
apparently Lauren Jacobs was stripped of
his ordination by the Messianic Jewish
movement five years ago they got a fake
fake Jew you can't write this stuff and
I haven't said that for a while send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
but mixing it up a lot on Twitter lately
not sure if you've noticed also the
program is on twitter at david pakman
show follow us quick break the
show for you today
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com let me say a big and quick
thank you to Kevin Griffin today who's
today's new member of the day this is a
program that doesn't just appear out of
thin air we are funded and supported by
really great people who choose to sign
up for membership like Kevin Griffin and
one of those folks who's been with us
for more than five years since 2013 is
Liz Tamayo today's sustaining long-term
member of the day join them at WWE at
Macomb and also please if you have two
minutes to take a survey for us we are
doing a survey to continue our outreach
and improve the program and improve
advertising opportunities so please go
to david pakman.com slash survey this
will take you two minutes and it'll
really provide us some valuable
information about our audience I would
really appreciate it if you did that
would be a big big help to the program
it is time for hatred mail and much like
what's going on in politics in general
hatred mail continues to get more
extreme and concerning if you've never
heard of hatred mail before this is what
we mean when we say hatred mail because
we cling to our guns and our God but
somehow totally cool with a billionaire
who wants to assault our wife patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America
cuz freedom today's hatred mail is
horrifying and I don't know what else to
tell you
let's take a listen to it and see if we
can make heads or tails out of it I used
to be left until I caught on to but it
like yours I thankfully only seen one
video of yours
do you make us out to be idiots you are
what leads to hashtag hashtag fake news
you are joining into an echo chamber of
leftist Tabuk you come like of as
complete idiot that last line aside this
is actually a really serious problem the
problem of projection from the right
exists on many issues as I talked about
at the top of the show today but on fake
news in particular it is a massive
problem because the right has very
successfully you know the things I give
Trump credit for are successful
propaganda initiatives and one of the
most successful ones has been the use of
fake news as a way to brand adversarial
and investigative news outlets and those
most loudly shouting about fake news are
actually the primary purveyors of that
fake news so this is a really serious
problem and it hasn't worked if you want
to anger the hatred or to tell them
you're not going to be pushed around by
them use the coupon code hey treat 40
when you sign up for a membership at WWJ
in pokémon calm you save 40% and 236
hatreds cry every single time you do it
and while you're on our website go to
david pakman.com slash survey take a
two-minute survey that will be really
useful to us in improving the show and
attracting advertisers that are a good
match for our audience
there's an interesting follow-up I want
to do about Kanye West the rapper and
hip-hop artist I don't really do much
celebrity culture stuff on the show I
don't really care about Kanye West's
opinions about issues in principle but
when he became arguably the most famous
black Trump supporter in the world and
started showing up at the White House
and wearing Magga hats
it it did become interesting and to
Kanye West made all sorts of strange
statements unclear whether we can
attribute them to political brainwashing
confusion ignorant or just him being off
his meds as he has said he is before
this included saying slavery was a
choice he had this very strange demeanor
as much indicative of as I as I said of
mental illness as political ignorant
when he showed up at the Oval Office
with Donald Trump for that now infamous
bizarre meeting and he has been
responsible for promoting supposed
former liberal and current fellow black
conservative Candace Owens who is one of
the most toxic Liars in the political
landscape right now and whatever was in
Kanye West's mind when he was doing this
stuff he has become a tool to provide
cover to those who want to argue that
Trump is great for black people and
other minorities whether or not that was
Kanye's intention he has been used in
that way and based on a series of tweets
that he sent last night he appears to
have broken with Trump and now says he
was used to promote things he doesn't
actually believe in which is exactly
what I've been saying for months let's
look at some of the tweets last night
starting with quote my eyes are now wide
open and now realize I've been used to
spread messages I don't believe in I am
distancing myself from politics and
completely focusing on being creative
also saying I support creating jobs and
opportunities for people who need them
the most
I support prison reform I support
common-sense gun laws that will make our
world safer I support those who risk
their lives to serve and protect us and
I support holding people who misuse
their power accountable I believe in
love and compassion for people seeking
asylum and parents who are fighting to
protect their children from violence and
war
so it appears Kanye is backing off of
Trump he's backing off of this movement
meant to get black people to quit the
Democratic Party without making any
actual political arguments about why
black people should leave the democratic
party and become Republicans and it's
really important to recognize that even
if we don't really care that much about
Kanye West's politics other people do
because of the size of his following so
I actually think Pat that even if we can
say this entire charade is attributable
to ignorance or mental illness or
whatever you want to say I do think it's
important that he went on Twitter and
said this well hey now that he's coming
out as slightly progressive at least if
you look at those tweets
maybe we can embrace him maybe maybe
Kanye West will become a fan of the
David Pakman show and we can go around
the country touring with them giving
speeches with him and he'll be our
biggest fan it'll be great
yeah that's the risk which is I still
don't really care what he thinks and I
have no interest in engaging with Kanye
West on on politics in particular I mean
I would of course gladly welcome him on
the program but I have no particular
interest in it but it does matter
because people do are influenced by what
he says and also importantly and this
was I'm really glad he did this he
specifically clarified that he has
nothing to do with this movement called
the black sit black exit from the
Democratic Party that Candace Owens is
involved in he tweeted about that as
well saying I introduced Candace to the
person who made the logo and they didn't
want their name on it so she used mine I
never wanted any association with blex
it I have nothing to do with it you have
to know what he's referring to to even
understand the tweet but that's what
he's talking about this Candace Owens
movement about black people leaving the
Democratic Party so question one is this
national nightmare of Kanye and Trump
coming to an end I hope that it is the
reality more than anything Pat is I see
a guy who's not well mentally I think
the best thing he can do is to just take
a break period not just from politics
and it's important that when I say that
you understand I'm not excusing Kanye's
decision as an adult to get involved
with Trump but he was displaying signs
of mania during that Oval Office visit
and in other videos he doesn't seem to
be doing well
but nobody forced him to meet with Trump
we should understand and empathize with
people who are struggling but the
decision to meet with Trump and to go to
the Oval Office was his decision
yeah he's certainly a very outspoken
individual but you can channel that
input it into something else
aside from politics at least for the
meantime I always find it very strange
when someone is initially a liberal and
then the next year they're conservative
and then they go back to being a liberal
I think it you know ruins their
credibility at least to me but other
people are ready to grab onto that and
as I said before take him around the
country and use him as their champion
yeah and the political awakening thing
that you mentioned we've talked about
that before and I just this isn't about
Kanye specifically it's not about
anybody specifically I don't know many
people that end up having significant
political awakenings where their
politics drastically change as adults
I'm not saying it doesn't happen it's a
country of three hundred and forty
million people of course that happens
but when someone claims that their
politics have changed so drastically and
Candace Owens I don't know how old she
is she must be around thirty and so she
was I guess in her mid to late 20s when
she had her awakening I think it's
important to look really closely at that
because it's not the most common thing
now the the right is all right was
looking online this morning
the right is already attacking Kanye
saying he's back on the plantation which
is how they like to say that black
people are slaves to the Democratic
Party it's already happening and that
there's no surprise there but big
picture this is good
bigger picture I still don't care what
Kanye really has to say about this stuff
make sure you follow me on instagram at
David Pakman followed the show on
instagram at david pakman show to see a
behind-the-scenes picture of the pat
cave at the new studio i will also be
doing a tour of the actual studio room
sometime soon
quick break we will be back right after
this the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show it
is great to be joined today by Nicole
Murphy who's the daughter of Paul
Kingston leader of the Kingston group
and profit and presiding priesthood of
the LDS Church is author of the leaders
daughter where to even start at this
point Nicole I mean it that your story
is so interesting maybe we can just give
our audience an overview of sort of the
religious upbringing that you were born
into and then maybe that will get us
talking about polygamy Mormonism and
everything else that's in your past all
right
ready when you are yeah no go ahead so I
mean were you what what religion were
you born into um I was born into so
there's a there's the mainstream
Mormonism and then there's the break off
of the fundamentalist Mormon Mormonism
and I'm from the break off where they
live polygamy they live consecration and
they live the original Mormon doctrine
whereas the mainstream has let some of
those original principles go a little
bit do you know at what point there was
this kind of separation where what we
would consider kind of like the modern
Mormon Mormon Church stopped adhering to
some of those original principles yeah
in 1890 then Utah was trying to become a
state and the problem that they were
running into is the government didn't
like polygamy and so they had to sign
the 1890 manifesto that stopped all
polygamous marriages
it didn't just it doesn't didn't disavow
the ones that were already in practice
but it did prevent new ones from
happening and then in the 1900s and
that's when they said no more pointless
marriages and they stopped everything
and what was sort of the dynamic of your
father's role within the Mormon Church
but also that this sort of offshoot so
my father was that I've never actually
in the mainstream Mormon Church his
grandfather started the
started my group in 1935 and my father
was born into it and what were some of
the characteristics of that subgroup so
that some group lives consecration where
they believe everything is turned into
the church and the church decides how
everything is is used all the resources
and everything fact it's a lot like
communism and then they also live
polygamy which is more than one life so
in thinking about your childhood you
were born into this
yeah it's first of all what what
percentage of them let's actually let me
even back up how big is this subgroup
and what percentage of that group is
living the polygamous lifestyle um
there's about 5,000 people and I would
say I would say 90% of them are living
polygamy and when you talk about living
polygamy we're talking about how many
wives in general my dad had 27 now
that's a lot for one man even in my own
group in fact the next one I know of is
his brother who have 15 most of them
have 3 or 4 or 5 the leaders all tend to
have more wives but the ones most of the
followers have two or three and when you
were growing up I mean at what age did
you realize that most of the world in
the United States is not polygamists I
was actually so my dad had me in a
public school for kindergarten and first
grade and then he pulled us out and put
us into his own school and then at that
point we weren't allowed to socialize
with anybody outside of our community
and so it wasn't until I was in my teens
14 15 years old my I graduated high
school and I had gone to college that I
realized that this wasn't normal and
when you were growing up did you
literally believe the other than the
lifestyle stuff were you sort of like a
literal believer in the doctrine and
teachings of Mormonism that were part of
your upbringing um actually I I believed
in all of it when I was
younger in fact when I was 12 years old
I planned on being a second third or
fourth wife I believed in all of it
until I until I got much older and
started seeing differences in the
outside opinions and the order opinions
the order is the name of the group I
come from and I just started seeing all
the differences and I realized how wrong
how wrong the polygamy part was that's
interesting so it was the polygamy part
specifically that was like the first
thing that struck you as something is
not right here yeah I watched my mom
live the lifestyle and I watched her
beauty I watched her very unhappy for a
lot of years and it really broke my
heart and it wasn't until I I had
actually spoken with other wives that
were also very unhappy that I realized
that it wasn't a happy lifestyle can you
talk a little bit about you said you
were on your way or thought you would
become a second third or fourth wife
what's the significance within the group
of being a first wife versus like a
subsequent wife the first wife is
usually the prettiest the one that is
capable of running the family I guess or
the one that is gonna run away if she
doesn't get to be first time and were
you starting to be sort of groomed in
this direction when you were I don't
know a kid a teenager like what starts
to be the preparation for being part of
that I feel like you're kind of groomed
from birth you're taught in your prayers
and I mean at 2 3 years old you're
taught to say your prayers and find the
person that God wants you to marry and
then it goes up you have marriage
classes starting from age 12 I your
group pretty much from birth to be the
spiritual life that they want you to be
and our they're people that resist or is
it basically total cultish groupthink
and and the sort of resistors are pretty
few and far between the resistors are
pretty few and far between in fact I'm
only the fifth of my father's 200 plus
children that have left I mean it's not
a couple leave sense to me but the
majority of them stay and believe in the
community and
when you have 200 kids do you even know
all of them do you remember the names of
all of them like what are the logistics
of that I don't think he knows I'm I
would say that he does not remember the
thought all the names and just doing
kind of math I mean I'm just we're gonna
get into the sort of philosophical
elements of leaving but just from math
if you have 20-something wives are you
spending like a day a month with each of
them or what what's the day-to-day life
of a polygamist my dad my dad hasn't
yeah you got to keep in mind my dad has
more wives than most but he came home
once every two or three months and it
was usually around birthdays and
anniversaries that he was home and then
went and then when my mom had an I every
2 or 3 months and he would come home for
that Wow I mean that's just that that
that is that is incredible so talk a
little bit about when you started to
sort of consider that this may not be
the place for you and kind of seriously
start to think about leaving um I have a
lot of sexual assault
growing up as a child and so that kind
of put me into a state of depression
where I felt like I felt like there was
something not right I didn't know what
it was but I knew that there was
something wrong with everything going on
and so that kind of planted the first
seeds and then as I got older and I went
to college and I started seeing
different different points of view there
was a lot of racism in my group and I
had a really hard time with that there
was it's a very sexist community and I
had a really hard time with that as well
so it just it just little seeds were
planted along the way to kind of lead me
astray I guess talk a little bit about
that so let maybe let's take the racism
part first like in what in what ways was
this a racist drew it so they originally
taught that black people have an extra
bone in their body that kind of goes to
show and then you're not allowed to
socialize with anybody of color you're
not allowed to marrying anybody of color
and that actually seems I mean at one
point that was sort of a mainstream
Mormon belief wasn't it that they have
backed off of over the last several
decades absolutely in fact it wasn't
until the 70s that that black people
could hold the priesthood in the
mainstream Mormon community they're
still not even close to that and point
me and then as far as the the sexism
part can you talk a little bit about the
ways that that manifested women are
pretty much just a tool they're not
really people where I come from is there
just a tool to for a guy to get to
heaven interesting and in terms of roles
within the community are there when it
comes even down to like jobs and that
type of thing I mean is it is it that's
specifically outlined what it is that
women are allowed to do they're pretty
much just told to do whatever their
husband tells them to some husbands will
want their wives to work to bring in
income some wives will have to stay home
with the kids and it just depends on
whatever the husband what role the
husband wants her to play in that family
and it's it really it really just is up
to the husband and how he governs his
own family so you start to develop a
plan to get out what what do you do how
do you think about it
honestly I took it one day at a time
it was really a struggle to even wrap my
mind around the fact that I was going to
leave and I kind of I kind of knew that
it was coming but I didn't I couldn't
really wrap my mind around what it meant
yeah and so it really was just I made a
plan and I put that plan into place and
I kind of just put one foot in front of
the other and then finally I realized I
was out and it just and it just
snowballs from there I got a job I did
have a lot of help in fact I had a
sensei that I was really close to and he
really just helped me put a plan into
place and say okay this is what an adult
does on the outside world and I mean
you've got to get a job maybe start
saving some money
you better have a car and he really
helped me put the logistics into place
and kind of helped me make a plan to
follow and Nicole when you say you had a
sensei are you using that word in the
sense of like this was a martial arts
teachers that have a different different
meaning that you're using
no he really was a martial arts teacher
I don't know if maybe like within the
within this group their sensei means
something else so who did you tell in
advance of leaving nobody I couldn't in
fact about three months before I left
then I sat down with my two closest
friends and I had told them this is the
choice that I'm making and I still love
you and I'm still here for you but I can
no longer stay in this community and one
of my friends asked me she said will you
wait until my wedding because if I left
before her wedding I would not be
allowed to attend and so I agreed I
waited until her wedding and I was one
of her bridesmaids and then after that
point then I that's when I left
do you I mean say as much or as little
about this as you want but if you still
live in physical proximity to where your
family is or have you moved very far I
haven't I've moved probably about thirty
minutes away from the majority of them
so it's not super far but it's not
they're not in my backyard
and you did you receive any contact from
people initially and are you still in
contact with people from your family a
lot of my full siblings I've kept in
contact with some of them have married
into the community and have become
second turned wives and they're not
allowed to speak to me but a lot of for
the majority I'm I do keep in contact
with my full siblings my mom and I
struggled but yeah I mean Izzy so is she
I guess first question is it strictly
speaking is she forbidden from having
contact with you she was initially not
necessarily forbidden but very strongly
discouraged and my siblings were all
forbidden to have contact with me for a
long time but then after they became 18
and and my dad kind of realized that you
know they he didn't really have as much
control over them but a lot of my
siblings are also forbidden from talking
to some of the people that are still in
the community because they talked to me
so there is that control in that aspect
of
can you talk a little bit about the ways
in which the organization the group
exerts control over people and whether
that's physical control or psychological
control and sort of like what you had to
break through in order to get out what
are the tactics that they use um it
really is more mental control than
anything as far as physical control my
dad tried to prevent me from buying a
car he took my money
so I wasn't allowed to as soon as he
realized what I was doing he took my
money and I wasn't allowed to take any
more of my money that I had earned so as
far as he does things like that
physically but a lot of it really is
mental and emotional control I mean if
you leave you're not allowed to see your
family you're considered the devil and
an apostate or whatever they whatever
word they use for it now but they just
it really is more mental and emotional
control when you talked about the fact
that there was sexual abuse is is in
general is there significant physical
abuse used either like as a discipline
tool or to ensure compliance yes so my
dad when I was six years old he actually
beat me with a piece of a bed as after
his brother went to prison for
third-degree child abuse I think it was
felony child abuse if I remember right
after he went to prison for that then a
lot of them stopped using such harsh
abuse tactics more because they were
afraid of going to prison but they do
still use very abusive tactics the last
thing I want to ask you about in the
limited time we have is in the United
States polygamy strictly speaking is
against the law so can you talk a little
bit about how that is circumvented and
and and sort of how they have this
de-facto polygamy even though it is
against the law the way that they get
around it is he doesn't actually marry
the subsequent wives he'll get a
marriage certificate for the first one
and then the second and third and fourth
it's just a spiritual ceremony so
technically there's really no way to
prove that they're living polygamy
because there's no
Porcello got it pretty straightforward
in fact yeah the book is incredible
we've been speaking with nicole Mafi
who's the author of the leaders daughter
she is the daughter of Paul Kingston
leader of the Kingston group and profit
and presiding priesthood of the LDS
Church Nicole thank you so much for
talking to me good thank you so much for
having me it's been a pleasure the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
this is pretty funny every once in a
while Anthony scaramouche she sort of
makes some sense but it's all sort of in
a very strange context and in case
you've forgotten
scaramouche II was trumps I guess maybe
third White House communications
director maybe even fourth didn't last
long just a few days and he showed up on
CNN and he was asked about a bunch of
different things and he said - he made
two statements that I found interesting
one is that he said Donald Trump likes
to lie and number two he said that
Donald Trump should probably tone down
the line lying it's sort of an awkward
exchange but I like it and I'm gonna
play some of it for you now let's take a
look do you think he knows he's lying
yeah I think he does yeah
so the reason I asked he likes it he
likes lying yeah he likes it because I
think he likes the fact that people are
talking about it and he likes the fact
that it's like taking my finger and like
putting in in one of the two eyes that
you like on your face who's that who's
on whose finger whose eyes is he putting
the finger in because that's the part of
it that I don't get if he likes lying
what would you call someone who likes
lying you know like a rascal like a
scoundrel you know like a yeah that's a
scandal yeah it's a smart there's a
smirk on his face when he's doing it I
mean there's a there's also an
entertainment aspect to it again I asked
you what do you call someone who likes
to lie you say a scoundrel and another
thing you could call someone who likes
to lie is a liar is he a liar okay well
we vote we both know that he's telling
lies okay so if you want me to say these
a liar I'm happy to say he's a liar but
I'm telling you that those people that I
wrote about in that book and the
research that I did on it on the levels
of the weighted average of what they
really care about they care way less
about that John and they care way more
about okay we finally have a president
that may be my advocate and so all of
that other nonsense that he does that
existential nonsense is less important
to them that maybe I just don't like and
I think you and I agree on I don't like
when people say oh because someone
didn't go to college they don't care
about lying because I know for a fact
that people do care about lying your
book the blue collar president well I
know you okay good let me rephrase it
because I think it's super important for
a better understand nobody should lie
I'm not a
believer in lying but politicians happen
you want to say that to the camera to
the president
nobody should lie mr. president and but
you know your politician now so
politicians lie when their lips are
moving and so all these people lie but
you should probably dial down the line
so there's a bunch of interesting stuff
here actually it's not just like another
weird scary Moochie moment to write off
number one scare Moochie says they don't
really care about trump's lying that the
trump's base doesn't really care about
trump's lying that's probably true what
you have to remember is that scaramouche
is also a huge huge liar
so it's interesting to hear his
perspective on Trump's lying I believe
that Trump's lying is much more
complicated than scaramouche II just
saying you probably shouldn't lie
anymore because Trump's lying seems to
be both pathological in nature but also
Trump actually seems to believe the lies
once he tells them enough times we we've
gotten reports like for example with the
three to five million illegals who
suppose supposedly voted for Hillary
Clinton we have a number of reports from
inside the administration that say Trump
talks about that privately or at least
as recently as a few months ago Trump
would continue talking with people about
that privately so it does appear that he
starts to actually believe the lies
number one number two there's been no
downside to Trump lying
he gets fact-checked and then they
called the fact checkers fake news or at
least his base does when his base can't
deny that he tells any lies they
basically do what scaramouche II did
here which is to say listen politicians
all lie but Trump is doing the right
thing so who really cares about the lies
in the end and that got me thinking
about the interview the more interesting
conversation to have with Anthony
scaramouche II would have been how the
lies even if the base doesn't care even
if politicians quote all lie what about
the impact that Trump's lies have on
other world leaders because just
insisting that scaramouche II called
Trump a liar which is what John Berman
did there it's entertaining but it
doesn't really get to the crux of the
issue and I saw comment on lying saying
calling Trump a liar for two years
hasn't dented his popularity so what's
really the point I agree with that but
that's disturbing the fact that people
are bored of the president constantly
telling the monster
lies is not good for the country it's
not good for democracy and it's this
hyper normalization where we are bored
now with stories about Donald Trump
telling demonstrable lies let's talk
about the proud boys militia which has
been banned on Facebook and
right-wingers are furious if you don't
know what the hell I'm talking about I
envy you the proud boys are this
right-wing militia group that's led by
right winger Gavin McInnes and they
engaged in violence in New York City
after a recent speech
mcinnis regularly encourages violence on
his program and another story that we've
been following have been the stories of
bands of Alex Jones's Infowars content
on a bunch of different platforms
YouTube as an example Twitter facebook
spotify others facebook has now
confirmed to Business Insider that they
are banning the proud boys and Gavin
McInnes from Facebook and from Instagram
Facebook's explanation as to why is that
they have clear rules about hate groups
that proud boys is a hate group that
McKenna's encourages that hate as a
leader of the group and that that's it
the proud boys are accused of attacking
protesters on October 12th of shouting
homophobic slurs of beating and kicking
protesters five of them have been
arrested so far and what's interesting
about the proud boys and horrible is
that their primary channel for
recruitment is the Internet they are
doing this with Facebook and and by
banning them Facebook is directly
preventing the growth of a hate group so
let's talk through the arguments against
this ban first of all the idea that this
is new is wrong
Twitter banned the proud boys back in
August that was before they beat
protesters in New York City so fewer
people knew about them secondly that
this is some kind of double standard and
people are already saying online what
about auntie feh well as soon as people
associated with auntie feh advocate for
violence on Facebook or Instagram or
recruit people to commit violent acts on
Facebook or Instagram I will be the
first one saying ban them you're looking
for people to defend violence on this
program whether it's from the left or
the right it's not going to be me maybe
Pat will defend them but not me and TIFF
I simply not organized in the same way
though where they are vetting and
recruiting members in this way
and thirdly Pat there's the free speech
argument conservatives have a very weak
case here because Facebook is a private
company they have Terms of Service
Facebook determined that those Terms of
Service have been violated if you want
to change the law to force Facebook to
have to allow this fight that battle but
nothing illegal is happening here
whatsoever and we actually have a piece
coming up about that paddle long-form
piece about social media and censorship
and free speech in terms of service
we're gonna outline that entire debate
that's only one part of this and the
other funny thing I don't know if you
saw this Pat is that there are people
saying
McInnis is Canadian he doesn't have
American citizenship and he's inciting
violence and a hate group why isn't he
being sent back to Canada but to which I
would say I would not hold my breath
waiting for that yeah that's pretty
interesting I think this this case is
more much more clear-cut than some of
the other ones like Alex Jones and some
other conservatives getting banned from
Facebook and other social media sites I
mean
Gavin McGinnis he went on Joe Rogan's
podcast he describes the proud boys as a
gang and said that the fourth step for
joining the gang and being fully
immersed in it is to commit an act of
violence like to get into a fight to get
arrested if that's not inciting violence
if that's not a hate group I don't know
what is and in you know II should
certainly be banned from those platforms
but maybe they should also look into
some sort of legal repercussions - yeah
and then I think that their response to
that which as many people have pointed
out rightly so that he said a bunch of
this stuff on Joe Rogan I guess we were
supposed to believe that it was satire I
haven't seen the episode I mean is it at
all believable to say it was he was
merely joking no I well I would say that
if you listen to him fully in context go
back and forth with Joe there I take him
at his word I don't think he was joking
I don't think it was satirical I think
Joe Rogan was taken aback by what Gavin
McInnes had to say but McGuinness
certainly came across as serious last
thing on this I don't want to be late or
something that really isn't that
controversial does anybody find it odd
that the proud boys are a group of white
men who feel oppressed and emasculated
in modern-day American culture like they
present as alpha males but when you
consider that in modern-day America
they're saying they are emasculated and
oppressed as white men is that actually
alpha behavior it's sort of something to
think about
we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting voicemail
I got connecting abortion and the
minimum wage take a listen to this yeah
I want to hear a Democrat come out and
say that an abortion is oftentimes an
economic necessity and if you think
abortion is murder and you don't want to
raise the minimum wage look at your own
hands you're dripping with blood the
bloods on your hands but of course
they're too mamby pamby there to fight
that card they will not fight yeah so
the point here that is being made is a
good one
whether or not you like the delivery
which is that a lot of abortions are
happening for economic reasons people
are otherwise open to the idea of having
a child but they recognize that their
economic circumstances wouldn't bring
that child into an environment that
would be a positive experience for that
child if you increase the minimum wage
you do enable more people to make the
choice responsibly not to have an
abortion but listen you're thinking like
two or three layers beyond just the the
obvious talking points that we hear from
the right so good luck getting them to
engage with you on that level we've got
a great bonus show coming up for you
today I hope you'll join us you can get
access by becoming a member at WWE
join pakman.com or by making a $5 a
month pledge on patreon at patreon.com
slash david patten show i look forward
to talking to you then
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you